Well, good afternoon everyone.
My name is Vint cerf.
I'm your chief Internet evangelist.
And that wasn't the title I
asked where I wanted arch Duke,
but he didn't work out.
We're here to talk about operation smile
and you don't want to hear that from me.
You want to hear that from the guy
that's going to actually make it happen.
And so I wanted to introduce Ruben Allah
to give you an idea of what this is all
about. And I've stolen, uh, his bio here,
so I need comes from Google, right?
So that means it must be correct. Um,
and I don't want to read the whole thing
cause he's going to tell us a little
bit about how he got involved
in this in the first place.
That's a story all by itself,
but he's a physician and he's a
public health specialist from Panama,
but he spent 25 years
with Operation Smile,
which tells you something about how
dedicated he has been to the project.
And by the time he's done with his talk
today, I think you'll understand why,
uh, he actually got involved when
he was still an undergraduate.
If I remember correctly, you were a
translator for the program is from Panama.
So he was helping the people who didn't
happen to speak Spanish, presumably, uh,
to, uh, execute on their,
on their project. Uh,
he's got all kinds of experience
with lots of organizations, uh,
dealing with health care
all around the world. And I,
I don't want to spend too much time,
frankly,
Ruben on your biography because what's
important is not what you've done but
what you're doing. And that's what
I want people to hear about. So, uh,
let's get room in up here to tell us
the story of operation smile and his
involvement in it.
So Ruben [inaudible]
the stage is yours.
Yeah,
good afternoon everybody.
It's really great to be here with you
today and we appreciate the time that
you've taken to actually come join us
and to those of you who are connected as
well, hopefully you'll enjoy this
story of hope and transformation.
I am speaking with Vince
before coming to join you.
He talks about the tire
that you all have as a,
as an organization to share knowledge,
allow people to learn,
allow people to collaborate and the
ability to get the knowledge to actually
create solutions to complex,
very, very complex problems.
And if we actually do do that every day,
if we actually do,
do solve problems that actually can
help the lives of people, uh, then,
then we have something, right. Um,
so my colleague and friend Chris,
Brian and I are here to
talk about operation smile.
And as you see in that you've seen
in the video, in the picture, um,
we take her children were born with a
facial deformity called cleft lip and
cleft palate. Uh, and this
kits, um, you know, are,
are coming to the world in
many different countries.
You actually have the ability to go
to take care of them in so many other
countries,
the treatment that they saw required
is not necessarily readily available,
but we can solve that problem.
So operation smile started back in 1982
and the Philippines and Dr. McGee and
his wife Cathy Mcgee went to
the Philippines. And I say,
I drove around the pool area,
say realize the amount of need.
But they're very quickly went into a
very nice hotel and they started driving
through, through, through the countryside.
And so the beautiful landscapes
and the beautiful children,
but nothing could have ever prepared him
to see what they saw in the small town
of Naga CT where they were supposed to
operate on about 50 children who were
born with cleft lips and palates.
300 of them came and their families.
So as they made their way
through the masters of people,
they could send some society,
the despair and they did take care
of those 50 children at that time.
And there were no plans of going back.
A woman came to Dr. McGee and
his wife and said, you know,
I have his basket of bananas that I like
to give you to say thank you for trying.
Thank you for trying.
Her kid had no received surgery,
but just the fact that
someone had actually tried
was meaningful enough for her
to probably give one of
the few things you had. Uh,
the director of the hospital
at that time said, you know,
if you ever get a chance to come back,
please come back because
these kids will still be here.
There might be five or 10 years
older. Um, but they'll still be here.
So they went back to the United States
live we can do to came back to live their
lives as usual, but they couldn't
stop thinking about these kids.
So they gather a whole bunch of friends
and went back in time and time again.
And that's how operation smile started.
And as they say in life,
there are no ordinary moments.
This was an extraordinary,
extraordinary moment that set in motion
a chain and a sequence of events that
has allowed many people like
you to actually be engaged
in this transformation.
We was talking about the fact that I was
born in Panama and up to the age of 16,
this is what I had seen of Panama.
This is a beautiful city,
the amazing beaches. If you ever
get a chance to visit, please visit.
I guarantee you'll enjoy
it. But beyond that, um, I,
I didn't really know they
need so my own country.
So when Operation Smart came in 1992,
this is what I saw,
hundreds of people again coming to Ho
to operation smile at the hospital.
And at that point I met
bill and Cathy Mcgee,
which was amazing. But I started asking
myself, what have these kids been?
Why haven't I never seen one of them?
And I started to learn about
the people, Panama, my con,
the country where is worn through
little Bartolo and his sister c,
but 12 was about two years old when his
sister was about eight years old and she
had traveled for five hours to get to
the place where operation smile was.
She had nothing but a couple of
changes, some diapers, a bottle,
a little pocket change,
and the normal responsibility of bending
her baby brother back with surgery and
hopefully a new lease in life.
Think about it, eight years old,
how many eight year old children that
you know, where that responsibility
so, but was sick, what operation
smile treated him. And he was,
by the end of the last day of surgery,
he was,
he was healthy enough for surgery and the
tears of his little sister as she held
him in the recovery room sort of
become this emotional symbol of what
transformation can be for people like
care for children like her. But they were,
they became the conduit for me to start
to learn about the needs of people in my
country.
And on the other side I saw hundreds of
volunteers coming together to actually
help them. So they will have a place
to sleep. So they have to food to eat.
So they have transportation in addition
to surgery. Uh, they could go back home,
um, knowing that they had been
truly cared for being careful.
This is the team that actually came to
Panama in 1992 and if you see there's a
brand dot and their side,
that's me at 16,
translating and learning.
When I go back to Panama,
I go back with a great sense of joy
because what I see now is my country mates
doing the work by themselves.
You see,
that group didn't just come to caretaker
children. They came to set an example.
They came to share the knowledge.
They came to use that knowledge to
create a change, to take action,
to solve a problem,
and that's spread like wildfire
and the people in my country,
and that's the sense of the
reasons of joy and pride.
Now when you see the pictures of
children with cleft lips and this,
this gap in the, in the, in the
mouth, you might think, well,
if you fix it for me, that's it, right?
This kids actually have to have
had to endure bullying, making fun.
We'd be made fun of being
ostracized so we can change that,
but it's much more than appearances is
much more than than than what you see.
These kids actually have
a lot of problems eating.
So imagine it's not just
the opening of the lid,
but I saw also in the opening
of the roof of your mouth,
whenever you go into a swimming pool and
you drink water and it goes through the
nose, it's very painful because there's
this openness, an open openness in,
in the roof of the mouth.
That's what these kids feel every
single time they try to feed.
So imagine you having a baby and trying
to feed this baby and the painful
experience that this baby has to go
through. So when we fix the deformity,
we enabled the baby to be
nourished properly, to feed
properly, to grow properly,
and to fight disease properly.
Imagine the moment among
holds her child and gifts. Uh,
I'm breastfeeds that moment is restored
and the beauty that goes along with it.
In addition to that,
because of that openness there is that
that whole children have a difficult time
speaking.
Um,
so when we actually do surgery
on them and we closed that,
that,
that it's not only about closing the hole
but actually putting the muscles where
there's the muscles are supposed to be.
Children are able to speak properly again
and then they're able to go to school.
They will to communicate with
their peers every three minutes,
somewhere in the world.
A child is being born this way,
but we have solution.
We can actually erase this formally.
We can actually take
care of these children.
There are many diseases in the world
that today we don't have a solution for.
We can correct this.
It just takes the ability to dream and
action to actually follow through and
create and turn that dream into a reality.
So we do believe that no child should
have to suffer from lack of access to safe
surgery.
But it isn't only about children.
And as you go through the chilled to two
through different towns and countries,
you understand the level of need.
And back in 1998 much younger
back then I met Rosa Maria Rosa.
Maria was a 73 year old woman and she
had lived her entire life with this
deformity and I couldn't help myself.
I had to ask her, but somebody, yeah,
for 73 years you have lived this way.
What made you finally get surgery
to what she promptly answered.
I didn't know I could get care.
I had no idea that it could get surgery
and these could be fixed and then she
said my entire life I have hoped to be
like any other woman to make me feel
pretty.
For an instance,
maybe even wear lipstick now too to the
females in this room and so many of us
when I think, well lipstick of all
things, but think about it for a second.
You get up in the morning,
you do your head hair,
you do your makeup and you
don't think about it twice.
This movement had dream about them
moment for 73 years I do news.
She got surgery and by the time she left,
all the female volunteers and
doctors and nurses had given her,
given her all the cosmetics
that you have brought,
probably likely enough
to last her lifetime.
So operation smile continues to try
to go to every corner of the earth.
And we've operated on boats,
we've operated on planes,
we have operator classrooms.
This is actually a project that we have.
We actually have to respond and we are
able to respond to some of the victims in
Haiti outside of the cliffs.
We've operated on tents.
We were looking to operate on mobile units
and frogs creating seven environments.
But we've also created infrastructure
that that allows kids to receive the very,
very best,
no matter where they are,
hospitals and centers that that
offered nothing but excellence, uh,
to these kids because we believe
that they all need save. Well,
Tom and effective surgery.
Now,
how many of you have had surgery
and raise your, your hands? Cool.
So the vast majority of you have
that surgery, believe it or not,
by the time you're 14,
15 about two thirds of you would have
needed some type of intervention.
And if that's the case, but you live in
a country where you don't have access,
what's the answer to
the rest of your future?
You might actually have to live
with disability or simply die.
Billions of people today
still are knocking the access
to safe surgery and the
poorest third of the world actually have
a very small amount of access to care
available. This is a problem we can
solve this problem we should solve.
And this is where you come in because
using your gifts is what enables people to
actually start making wave and,
and solving complex problems
like the ones we discussed. Um,
you have the ability to actually take
someone from the shadows and give that
person the ability to live a normal,
happy, fulfilling life. And He's,
when you actually make a change in
someone's life is not that person.
Is that family, is that
community? Certainly the,
to me,
someone like doing Alex who story I'll
tell you represents sort of the best in
humanity and the people who are impacted
by what you might do or what your,
what you do and in turn take that energy
and continue the chain of positive
actions. So here's he's, he's holding
his little kid and this is don't Alix.
And as I asked them, Alex, no, Alex,
what do you feel when you realized
that your child had been born this way?
And as he tells me the experience,
this is many years after he starts
to cry and he says, I was hopeless.
I was ready to sell my little house on
and the little car that I had inherited
because I knew I had to go
for care for a to my child.
He didn't have to because of volunteers
and members of operation, smile team,
he's baby kid. Boy was able
to get surgery. What, what's
remarkable about them,
Alex, is that he realized that he wasn't
the only one who was in that situation.
So he started going around his
region of Alachua in Honduras,
making sure that any child
who was born this way,
we'll make his or her
way to operation smile.
And these are some of the families that
through him having able to make it to
operations from Honduras to get care.
So every action that is positive and
makes a change in the lives of people
creates actually an avalanche
of really positive things.
And because of that is that I,
I tell you today, we need you.
It's the reason we need you
because we can dream bigger.
What if through all the
different tools and,
and opportunities that you
create with your knowledge,
we were able to not only my powder,
how fireline show is,
but where all the children that
he's found and the children who, um,
we need to make sure I continue to get
care and they once were being born, who,
who might not be able to understand how
far they had to get to and how can we
make sure that we use that knowledge to
offer assistance so that they can make
it to a place where they
can get the care they need.
What if we use the tools at our disposal
to make sure that not a single mom has
to software because she doesn't know
that her child can actually get care.
Today there about 7 million people who
made 7 million healthcare workers in the
world. We're still required to
take care of the needs of people,
so we have to train more providers.
What if we're able to use the tools
are this puzzle to make sure that the
knowledge is readily available
so that more people engage,
some more people create so
that more people share so
that more people give their
talents to,
to actually create this opportunity
to give someone a chance,
um, and do so in the most, normally
the most more knowledgeable,
knowledgeable ways,
but the humane ways.
What if we were able to look at how the,
the supplies and equipment,
our source I sharing and putting the
right places in a way that's efficient so
that not a single operating room where
children are being transformed will ever
lack any piece of equipment.
Now here's another one.
Today we have the ability to operate in
this kids. But if you were to ask me,
do we know what the best technique is,
I will have to tell you no.
And what happens is many surgeons will
tell you the best technique to take care
of his kids is the technique that
the surgeon is most comfortable with.
I don't know about you, but that doesn't
make me feel very warm and fuzzy.
I mean you don't go to and have
cardiac surgery and say, you know,
I don't know what
technique is the best one,
but I'll use my own and see how he goes.
But because we have the ability to
look at the before and the after,
what if we were able to use modeling
to understand how symmetry and soap
happening and matched that they're
really good outcomes to the,
to the techniques and now we're not
talking about a manual process of those
kinds of surgeries.
We could actually be taking the knowledge
of thousands of surgeries operations,
operation smart has Oprah in over
300,000 children and would not knowledge.
We could actually come back to the
surgeons or anybody who wants to learn to
actually take care of this case and says
this is the way to take care of them.
This is the one that's going
to give them the best result.
This is the one that's going to give
a chance to kids. So actually smile.
You may or may not know,
but we believe that change
starts with the young people.
And because we believe that we
have to take action for those and,
and decades and hundreds of years to come,
we have to empower the young people
to start a movement or to grow their
movement. Operation Smile
has very proudly, um,
join forces for decades now with,
with high school students now with middle
school students or university students,
they might not be doctors and nurses,
but they have no ulterior motives.
If they say,
I want to help a kid,
what they say so much more pristine and
beautiful and genuine that anything am I
able to be able to say.
So if they are telling us it's change
starts with me and we give them a platform
to advocate, to make those changes,
to, to spread the message, to educate,
to engage,
to actually say everyone can smile and
to actually empower them to continue to
say, we won't stop until we heal.
I think we're on to something.
Last but not least today,
we have the ability to correct the
deformity. But I have to tell you,
we don't have the ability to avoid
it from happening, ultimately.
Like to be out of a job. We'd like
to be able to say, we have to stop.
We can stop this from
happening all together.
So how about the ability to generate
that knowledge, to investigate,
to research and to come up with
the, with the ways to avoid, um,
a child from having to be born
into this world with this,
with this disease where this 4 million,
so
we know that if in the, in,
in a, in some parts of Asia,
one in every 500 children is one this way.
We know that in the United States,
one of every thousand children,
there's one this way.
So it's interesting if you take someone
from Asia, from that population in Asia,
and they moved to the United
States a couple generations later,
if they haven't mixed, the incidence goes
from one in 500 to one in a thousand.
So we know that there's something in
the genetics that's interacting with the
environment that's triggering
the deformity, that's,
that's creating this thing from half ever.
And,
but if we are able to avoid it
from happening altogether, um,
that will be something truly
celebrate in a nutshell.
Whenever we see a kid in
an empty operating room,
in some remote region of the world,
we know today,
we can actually feel that with
supplies and teams and people who are
knowledgeable, who are kindhearted,
who actually want to make a change.
But for that to happen,
many more people have to actually engage.
So when you actually decide to
join us to actually support us,
whether it's with resources or time or,
or your talents and your knowledge,
you become the heroes.
It might be true that in that operating
room there's a doctor, a nurse, a, an a,
an an a scrub nurse and Nsse ologist.
But you are truly the ones for
enabling that bridges moment to happen.
I'll stop with this. Um, the
story a couple of years ago,
I was empire way and I met Carlos and
one of the recovery room and other
recovery roommates see Carlos with his
baby rock and his baby and singing to her
and rocking her and singing
to her so much love.
And as I'm filling out the medical record,
I couldn't help but be
moved by the moment.
And I asked the nurse if she knew
anything about it and he said, well,
mom sort of left them because she
couldn't deal with the fact that the baby
would have been more with a deformity.
So He's been raising this child by
himself. I walked to Carlos and I said,
you know, I hope you won't mind
me saying this, but I've seen you.
I've seen the way you love your kid.
And if at some point I get a,
I get to be fortunate enough to be a
dad and I'm fortunate enough to love my
child half as much as yours, as you love
yours, I will consider myself a very,
very fortunate man.
So a few months ago I
gave a welcome to my, my,
my little baby girl,
Amelia.
But the reason I show you will do this
picture is not only because of the joy
that she brings to me,
but because of that memory of that
commitment to be a good father,
to be a loving father,
to be a loving member of our communities.
And societies have to
actually do something about
the ones for less fortunate
than I am.
So on behalf of every single operation,
smile member in the world who
would spend every ounce of energy,
who will see beauty in every single one
of his children who would actually share
with you the excitement that we feel
every time we bring a kid out of the
operating room and give it back
to mom, to you, the thinkers,
the innovators,
the dreamers.
We asked you to join us and we
give thanks for everything you do.
Okay.
I think I'm going to
stand here and cry for it.
We're going to do a little Q and a and I
already have a couple of questions that
I want to,
you have to stand up.
This is the way we treat our guests here.
Yeah,
there you go. So, um, well
I don't know about you,
but every, every time I hear this story,
you know, it really, it's very touching.
But you began at the very end to tell
us a little bit about what causes this
condition. And the answer is we actually
don't know. Is that right? Yeah.
Well, when many, many diseases,
you can actually identify the
disease to a specific chromosome,
even to a specific gene with clapping.
We have many different genes that
are involved and we're still actually
discovering some potential genes
that have some influence over, over,
over the creation of this is a 4
million. Now this, this happens,
if you think about it,
this is me,
happens anywhere from the four to 12 a
week of gestation. So when, when the, the,
the mom's side of the earliest,
uh, uh, parts of pregnancy,
anything that my impact,
that beautiful process of sales coming
together and an organ we informed, uh,
could potentially impact, um, the process
in itself and end up in a, in a club.
So we're still trying to figure
out not only all the genes,
but also the interactions between
those genes and the environment.
So is there evidence that it's
genetic, you know, there's,
are their families for example,
that have a higher percentage of children
born with this condition and other
families do? Correct? Correct. So
you do, you make a practice of, uh,
by the way you guys have questions,
you should be thinking about them and
their microphones on either side of the
room so that you should take
advantage of that. Um, is it,
are you taking DNA samples,
for example,
from errands in children and
accumulating that overtime?
It seems to me are kinds of
neural networks are pattern
matching algorithms and
other kinds of big data analysis might
allow us to find correlations, um,
between the genetic information and the
children that we discovered with this
condition.
Certainly.
Um,
a few years ago we actually
started collecting DNA samples.
Now it's a lot easier because
the samples now or just swaps or,
or saliva we take, so it's not
intrusive to, to children and families.
But we understood that by
explaining to them the,
the opportunity that they were given
us to maybe stop this from happening
altogether, that we would, we,
we felt that we could have their support
and we have got an overwhelming support
from the family. So we actually have the
largest repository of DNA information,
um, and different
populations in the world. Um,
we've started to study it and we continue
collecting the samples because we
believe that,
um,
when we're able to actually
finally target specific areas and,
and the environment,
the relationship with gene environment,
we'll be able to start
solving this problem.
You mentioned that you see different
incidences of this condition in different
parts of the world.
Um,
so that suggests that you mentioned
the environmental conditions,
which might include viruses or bacteria
as well as genetics might have a role to
play.
It seems to me we have a companies and
even know which are called Calico and
California Life Company.
It's trying,
it notices that people get old and it's
trying to figure out how to stop that.
And I'm interested in that
for obvious reasons. Uh,
unfortunately the engineers
misinterpreted that.
It's sort of like that's the fastest
way to make sure nobody gets old.
That's not the solution is the
problem that we're looking for. Uh,
but they're trying to look for
genetic evidence from centenarians.
What is it about the people who
live to a hundred years or more?
What is it about their
genetics than mine correlate?
So I just wonder if the tools that they're
using might conceivably be applicable
to this problem.
First of all, I was really interested in
that product as well. Uh, but absolutely,
yes.
You know,
the same process of understanding how
we are impacted by what's around us.
Um, and the richness of information that
we have within ourselves or impact that
it's can be replicated in
that way. So, you know,
now when we know today that nutrition
plays a role, we know that potential, uh,
medications play a role. We
know that alcohol, tobacco,
some drugs might play a role, but how do
you explain that to a mom who's never,
well, you can't, but,
but think about Zika,
which had such a dramatic effect
on children and microcephaly.
We were able to discover that
correlation very, very quickly.
But I think it was
because it was in Brazil,
the first incident is starting to
show up and it was extremely intense.
Large numbers, written relative terms
were happening all at the same time.
And so the correlation was
established there. Here we have, uh,
what I guess is a more diffuse effect
and much harder to food discovery.
Um, if you have questions, you should
use the microphones and if you don't,
I'm going to keep going.
Uh,
so how long does it take to train a
surgeon to perform this procedure?
And the implication of,
one of the things you said is it is not
exactly the same procedure every time.
It depends on the nature of the deformity,
how you choose to resolve it.
So this sounds like it's not a
simple, uh, training program. What,
how long and how hard is that?
So I'm going to say the procedure of
taking of a child with a cleft lip,
it's a shortest, 45 minutes.
In 45 minutes or less,
you can actually transform
the life of a kid. And,
and the pilot surgery takes about an
hour to an hour and a half by the the,
the United States for instance.
It's certainly this would take
care of these of these um,
problem would have trained 14 years after
high school to be able to finally take
care of this. But you know,
today many of them are saying we,
there would be ways to streamline this
training so that it's not so long so that
more people in the world have access
to the knowledge base and tools to take
care of this, of, of, of, of this,
uh, formative and but, but again,
he gets runs the,
it gets them to be a little bit more
complex because there's such where ID and
in techniques, but going back, what
if we actually had the best technique?
Why did we were able to categorically say,
if you do this card here and this
Martin here and this flap here,
you will have a really
good result for the kids.
Then you can shorten
that amount of training.
Well, there certainly are a lot of,
I'm not an expert in surgery. You are.
But my impression is that there are
surgical protocols that are fairly well
defined for certain kinds of conditions.
And so maybe there's a triage here where
there are a set of situations that are
solved fairly readily and obviously
with a particular procedure.
And then the others that
are more complicated.
We have classroom night over there.
You want to say who you are and then,
yeah, sure. Eli Is Pinto here. I'm
a cloud. See you in New York. Um,
you kind of already touched a little
bit and when I was going to go around
training,
but here's a question to you.
So what do you think is the
biggest challenge right now? Is it,
is it finding the people? Is it
the logistics of getting the, uh,
or quality stuff down to those locations?
Is it money?
Is it just training? And then the,
that's the segue from the last question.
What do you think is the biggest
thing preventing the next big push?
The next big, big plateau.
Does that make sense?
Yes, absolutely. I realize that's
a great question. First of all,
I gotta say thank you for being at the
top in the front of the other room. Um,
so it's, it's really all, all
of them, all of the above.
So we have the ability to actually
put some resources into the problem.
But do we have, how are we putting
enough resources into them?
But if you look at that as
trying to solve the supply may,
let's say I put more doctors,
we created more hospitals,
we put together more operating rooms.
That still doesn't solve the
problem itself because our children,
their families have all these barriers
before they even get it get to us.
So we put a great team to offer care
in a very, very remote location.
And sometimes they still have to
travel 10 12 hours to even get to us.
And that 10 to 12 hour trajectory means
that they have to invest whatever little
money they might have.
Some of them even borrow from
the village to even get to us.
So more so some of the, the barriers are
related to money. So much geographical,
someone or just knowledge, you know,
people aren't saying if you go,
something bad will happen to you or
you shouldn't go because you've been,
this is, this is your punishment
for something you did, Eh,
or your family has done.
So there's this belief in some places
that that's life and there's no solution
for it and you have to live
through your punishment. So, um,
I guess what I'm saying is there's not
a simple solution. There's not a, uh,
one, one thing I do will fix
this problem, um, today. Um,
but we do have to start looking at how
we train people better so they're more
out there.
How,
how we are in more equitable and the
things that we do so that we don't forget
about the poorest or the most
marginalized or are they more of the mass,
the ones who most remote.
Um,
it isn't only about the doctors and the
nurses and the hospital is about truly
understanding the people who are
suffering from this deformity and all the
things that are stopping
them from getting to us. Um,
but I think there's an amazing opportunity
again with, with uh, a group of, of,
of individuals and really smart and
innovative as you to actually figure out
some of the solutions.
It matters a great deal to them.
And if I happen to believe that
if we are fair, if we're honest,
and then then we'll actually be able to
make a change in their lives and in turn
they will impact our lives in a
positive way as well. You can ask her
if I may.
Um,
so if I heard you correctly
then the biggest challenge
to reach in the next spot,
so really happens way before
they even show up. Right.
And I'm trying to think of
ways that Google can help,
whether it is empowering the government
and in spreading out that information,
and it sounds to me,
correct me if I'm wrong,
were comedies is that challenge of with
the ramp of up to the person showing him
that solving that set of
problems is, is, is what,
that's one that's, that's important.
And that's maybe why I showed that map.
Because a lot of places in the world,
a lot of countries do not even
know this is a significant problem.
There's not a registry. So
until we go there and you
say, luck, we like to do this,
they don't realize that hundreds of kids
or our people are having to deal with
this.
And all of a sudden,
what if we were able to actually mad
the areas where this kids are so we can
actually do follow up if we
know that they're really far,
how do we help them get to us?
Um, if we, if we understand from,
from the ones who come to us or
they're having other issues in terms of
knowledge and beliefs, how do
we address those as well? Um,
but you know,
it'll,
it'll take something that enormous amount
of resources and talent and commitment
to actually make it happen, but
we can make it happen. So yes,
we have a question over here.
Thank you for coming. Talk to you. But
from my personal experience is not mine,
but my cousins,
my cousin is younger to me
and he just married yesterday.
Yeah. Yesterday. And he had a cleft, um,
from the very beginning when I believe
they did try the surgery when he was
seven or eight years old. That was
the first shot he faces a little bit.
But then he went again. Um, I never,
I mean I will definitely understandably
naive. I always had an excuse.
I was the younger one,
but I think that the entire family didn't
really know what was going on because
of the grades and the school performance
and nobody knew that everybody thought
they existed. How the brain
is just list. Um, and um,
but now he's married,
he's an engineer,
but it took him a lot of it for it to
get where he was a and multiple surgeries
and I guess there was a
couple of decades ago,
so I'm sure things have advanced a bit,
but what are the success scenario?
This is when they looked at
that I thought like, wow,
that's amazing that I haven't
seen in practice. Um, in my,
in others like looking at my
whatever sample set I have seen, um,
and that was also in India. So where there
could be a, not at the top of the line,
surgical a surgery procedures,
I have to keep her in that
area as much as here. Um,
my main channel is more like how would,
if you wouldn't know there wasn't Google
there then either like I could just
Google it and put the picture in
search. Hey, what is this? So,
um,
how would things have been
different if he would be 20 years
younger and we were born now
that's a great question.
First of all, congratulations.
That's amazing that he just got
married and that's exactly the, the,
the type of story you want to tell because
kids were born this way should have
the opportunity to live a full and
happy life. So that's fantastic. But um,
I imagine that you're talking about
a couple that gets out, go in India,
that your family,
we actually have to go through
the hardship of having to
figure out how to offer
a care. Now, you mentioned he
was operated at the age of six,
but if I were to tell you that today,
operation smile operates,
takes care of these kids from three months
on a ball above in the United States
in a few weeks after birth,
the kids are being taken care of.
So we do three to six months,
started the surgical process out of
maintaining a level of safety courses,
obviously surgery. So we want to
make sure the kid is strong enough,
but the younger you take care of them,
the, the, the skying is probably least,
least likely to actually be noticed.
Um,
in an ideal scenario, this is the outcome
that you want. You know, a child who,
who looks beautiful and you can barely
tell. Um, but sometimes it'd be as,
as soon as the surgery,
the outcome might not be the best one.
So maybe a little short. So you have
to go on and read through the surgery.
And that's again why it's so important
to understand what the surgeons that are
getting these beautiful outcomes and
learn from those surgeons consistently and
throughout now.
So the rate of success to actually be
able to take care of a kid 45 minutes,
it's doable. The Red of success,
uh, in the hands of experts is,
is really, really very high. And that's
why it's so important to train. Um,
but your story is one of hope because
he was able to grow even through the
hardship of getting a treatment later.
But you post a question, what if,
uh,
he had been born today,
it would have been easy to find out a
little bit or get a picture and find out
where he could go to
actually receive a treatment.
That would have been really nice. Right?
So information, it gives you choices,
but what about places in the world?
But there's still no information.
There are places in the world would,
you still don't have access? Uh,
so hopefully at some point soon
and we'll, we'll, you know,
anywhere in the world, a family may
have access to through our mobile unit,
him and sometimes in a conscious where
you don't have a computer where you have
a alum phone is actually pretty pervasive.
It used to be that that wasn't the case.
But what if every single family and in
any village in the world and in this
small little town could actually find
out that, oh, my child was born this way,
but I can get care. So it would be a
different story. Right? So you, you,
he wouldn't have had to
wait until six years old,
but today if we actually
made this possible,
then maybe children shouldn't weighed
more than a few months to actually get
this taken care of.
So this raises a very
interesting possibility. And we,
we've been doing work on facial modeling,
for example,
which you alluded to in your talk,
uh, in order to try to understand,
you know, what would happen if
we perform surgery on this child?
What might the outcome look like? That's
helpful for the family to understand.
But I can imagine having a family that
takes a photo with their mobile phone and
instead of saying,
find me more pictures like this,
which was one of the features
that we have a, it would be,
what can I do about this? Um, you
know, show me places that, uh, that,
uh, can treat this, uh, visible situation.
Uh,
that's sounds almost doable.
It sounds like we could find
a way to take a picture.
You're like that do a search. They would
turn up operation smile for example.
So we ought to think about it.
Yeah. And he goes back to their
license. Original question,
what else can we do with that?
We have the ability to do
the, um, the other thing,
the point about people getting
online were only 50% penetrated,
uh,
globally.
So when I was talking to Eric Schmidt the
other day informed me I wasn't allowed
to retire cause we're only 50% done.
I have another 3.5 billion
people to get online. So,
so much for any, any retirement
plans. [inaudible] um,
I'm wondering,
uh,
about the facilities that you
need in order to do the surgery.
I mean,
is this is,
this isn't exactly like a field
hospital thing, but I mean, what,
what kinds of conditions are adequate in
order to do this, this sort of surgery?
That's a good question because again,
when you take a kid from the
arms of a mom and her dad,
you want to make sure that you
give that kid back. It's a huge,
almost sacred
responsibility. You will. Um,
so where can you take care of his kids
in a way that is safe and Alfresco?
High Quality Operation Smart has been
able to perfect a model through standards
that were created with experts from around
the world to make sure that the right
anesthesia machines, the right,
um, uh, oxygen supply, the rive,
anesthetic gases, et Cetera,
et cetera are available.
So we can actually go to a
very remote hospital. And, um,
she was asked where they'll burn room,
there are lights on the oxygen and we
bring actually everything else that that's
required for that kid to get that very,
very safe surgery at that time.
And we're very proud of that.
But,
but we're wanting to do is go beyond that.
I mean,
it shouldn't be an episodic
thing or even in this,
and we have centers that are download
centers that work year round.
But if I go to a very remote town and I,
and I leave,
am I taking care of x
amount of kids? But, um,
but I have to figure out a way to
continue to help that town. Um,
so our cofounder almost
say, oh, it says, you know,
kids with cleft lips and palates actually
give us a chance to learn through them
about the needs of their communities.
Um,
so we've started to actually get more
engaged in, in areas related to safe,
the safety of surgery, so that a lot
of places that are very remote, um,
I start to be an access to the
proper anesthesia machines,
instruments a supply so
that not only their kids,
but the family members
can actually get surgery.
And if we do do help this
system of health of a country,
then it's less likely that they need,
will be so overwhelming and then we can
actually work together with either of
those governments or the community.
You know, a lot of people put the,
the responsibility on governments
and so you have to take care of this.
But health, which is a
right, it's a responsibility,
responsibility that all of us share.
Um,
so everybody in the community can actually
do something to create units like the
ones that we create, um, in,
in more remote areas and to make
them be there for the long haul.
What happens post up,
I mean,
you worry about things like
infection and everything else.
So how long do you need to
keep the children in the
hospital or somewhere where
you can be, you know, avoid disease
and infections and things like that.
So he's actually quite simple.
When you take care of a kid
with a cleft lip and palate,
they can actually go home by the
next day. That's amazing. Um,
I mean obviously we have to make sure
that there's proper coverage and the
antibiotics, they have proper
medications, but we actually, um,
see them at the very least three to seven
days after surgery to make sure that
everything is okay. But you pose a
question that is a big parcel for us.
So we want to see their kids six
months later, three months later,
nine months later. But, um, if the
kid has traveled 12 hours on a boat,
on a donkey,
on a horse or whatever,
how do you make sure that you're
able to see that kid again?
And you're at ease that the,
let's hope that the mobile phones and
the camera's [inaudible] sort of remote
diagnosis,
remote
health care, uh, has this
Marlo the plane there Coreg
bill and today what we do it,
we still send teams out to actually
make sure that the kids are great,
but every single one of these
actions requires time and resources.
If we are able to use tools that enables
to be more efficient and still offer
really high quality care,
then we can actually reinvest
those resources in to
taking care of more and more
kids and train more and more people,
you know,
would almost imagine that
you've seen these photographs.
It's dramatic.
You would think that because of
the dramatic positive outcome,
this would stimulate interest in
creating the hospital facilities in those
remote villages.
Having seen what medicine can do in
this point and very dramatic case.
And so that might, uh, might stimulate
provision of better health care.
And it's certainly a message to deliver
to countries that are struggling with
the health of their
population. Um, let me just,
uh, round this up unless there are
other questions from others here.
Um, and ask you once again, um,
to tell us a little bit more about the
opportunities that we have as individuals
and maybe as a corporation to contribute
to operation smile and its success.
You mentioned quite a long list
of things that that could be done.
Is there a place on the website that
says here are the things that we need
people to do or to contribute or to take
action about? Would we find out on the
website? And the website is mainly
an awareness and opportunity tool.
Uh,
and that allows people to get educated
and understanding this is a problem that
can be fixed and allows us to have garlic,
gather the resources.
But this goes back to again, the same
question and how to, is asking. It's like,
how can we help? Which is a beautiful
question to us. Certainly resources. Um,
uh, and Google is very, very
generous when, when, um,
employees or staff or team
members give a of their,
the resources who will match it.
It's, and that's one way to give, but,
but there's more ways to engage.
And if you think about it,
and I mentioned this in an operating
room, you have a doctor, a nurse,
and an anesthesiologist
before that moment happens,
a lot of people have had to actually
make a decision that that problem is a
problem. Uh, our cofounders,
you shall assess, you know,
love is a decision to make someone
else's problem your problem. Um,
so when we look at normally
given resources, what do
you have time it's, is, is,
is important. So there are ways
of volunteering. Um, you know,
we not only have doctors and
nurses who actually help us,
we have many nonmedical medical
volunteers who, who's doing,
if somebody from Google volunteer, what
would, what would we, what would happen?
They couldn't help us with
medical records. They could
help us manage, um, the,
the environment where kids or
families feel very comfortable, uh,
interact with them.
Listen,
we have the ability to not only offer
care but actually transform a hospital
that might be like a very,
very dark place and to a place of hope.
And that it's not something
the doctors usually doing.
So when we see a kid that comes in on
an operating room and they just grabbed
our hands and follow us,
we know that many volunteers,
I've actually made that kid and the
parents feel welcome, feel care for.
I feel appreciate it with dignity.
And that's what a lot of our non medical
volunteers are able to do with us.
And listen,
certainly outline at a serious of
potential opportunities for solutions to
problems that are complex in
the way we look at them today.
Because my brain doesn't work the
way you're still the US or, or,
or our friends here do put.
But I am sure that someone here
or someone connected here, um,
is already thinking about how do I make
sure that people figured this out better?
How to make sure that we can
actually fix this problem.
How do we make sure that we actually
have avoid this from happening?
What knowledge do I bring us as,
as a,
as an innovator that can
tell great people, hey,
you've been doing a good job, or we can
make it better. We can do it better.
No, thank you so much Ruben, for
telling us this story. It's, uh,
it's all about human dignity and it's
restoration and that's something we could
all we for.
So I hope that everybody who's out there
listening and maybe watching this video
later, we'll take the opportunity, take
the opportunity to help operation smile,
create some more smiles all around
the world. Thank you so much.
[inaudible].